the worldwide state of emergency due to
the current pandemic has again not
stopped at important film releases this
week especially Sony Pictures postpone
further films that should have been
released this year among them so far are
the Uncharted movie the new Ghostbusters
film afterlife and Mobius which all have
been postponed until next year currently
not yet affected are the two films
Monster Hunter which is scheduled to be
released on September 4th and rhenium 2
which is scheduled to be released on
October 2nd this year in a separate
press statement Sony announced that the
production of Uncharted was stopped only
a few days before the start of shooting
in March the situation is different with
the already cinema ready firm Mobius
which should have been released at the
end of July and is now just like
Ghostbusters after life not expected to
be released until mid-march next year of
course we will keep you informed about
further postponements while estar was
serious then mandalorian has already
been running in the USA since last
autumn large parts of Europe have only
had access to Disney Plus serious for a
few days and weeks now there is a new
rumor by the well-connected journalist
Jason watt as Halloween actress Jamie
Lee Curtis has already been seen more
often on the set of the mandalorian on
the last few days
what who actually is not a big fan of
unfounded rumors nevertheless wants to
provide us with some news in times of
domestic isolation and boredom he also
adds that in case his assumption about
the mandalorian doesn't hold true the
set of James Cameron's Avatar 2 is also
worth a visit by Jamie Lee Curtis so we
even have two rumours in one if Jason
watt who's rumours oftentimes provides
to be true in the past is right or not
we will surely find out in the near
future last year it didn't really look
like The Fast and Furious spin-off Hobbs
and Shaw would be continued in a near
future because the movie only made major
box-office takings
at the US theaters due to the slightly
late release in China the movie became
more popular than expected and earned
love almost 760 million u.s. dollar
there was no mention of a sequel until
Dwayne Johnson announced in a Q&A on
Instagram that a sequel to hops and Shah
is already been working on and al
Johnson is really looking forward to it
he didn't want to give away any further
details he just explained that they are
currently thinking about the direction
the secret will take and a far from
being able to give details about the
content
if Johnson's character Luke hops will
save the world from a dangerous virus in
the second part or if the creator's will
decide for a completely different
storyline we will probably find out in a
few month anyone who was not satisfied
with the open end of the third season of
Castlevania which was released last
month will soon be able to look forwards
to new content as Netflix announced a
few days ago by a Twitter that they are
planning a fourth season of the
animation series so the protagonist and
vampire hunter Trevor Belmont and his
companions will meet new powers of
darkness in another season how many
episodes the fourth season will include
is not yet known but it can be assumed
that a new season will have 12 episodes
because the first season had six to
second eighth and the third ten episodes
by the way the first season of the
series was one of Netflix 20th
most-watched in-house productions in
2017 and unlike many other video game
adaptations it gained quite a bit of
popularity and exact release date for
Castlevania is not yet known in addition
to Castlevania Netflix also announced
the second season of the also very
popular lock and key since the series
debuted at the beginning of February
lock and key has become more and more
the favorite of the serious Watchers and
so it's not to be surprising that
Netflix is planning a second season for
this streaming giant once again higher
the series producers Carlton Cuse and
Meredith Averell so it's safe to assume
that we get to know even more background
information about the diamond arch and
the power of the keys because the comic
template uses over 30 keys more than
twice as many as in the first season
unfortunately there's no release date of
lock and key
at the moment since even the script
would be finished already they would
have to wait a lot longer until they can
start shooting because of the current
situation
[Music]